186 metros de orgullo ruso hundidos en
el mar negro un arma de 12 mil 500
toneladas y una capacidad de hasta 680
efectivos a bordo en servicio desde 1983
se utilizó en la guerra fría en la que
porta armas nucleares incluso llegó a
ser el escenario previsto de un
encuentro entre el ex presidente de eeuu
george hw bush y el entonces el líder
soviético mijail gorbachov fue un cara a
cara que el mal clima obligó a celebrar
en otro navío en un puerto de malta en
los últimos años participó en varios
operativos entre los que destacan la
anexión de crimea y la guerra en siria
esta última sobre el mediterráneo en
defensa de la base rusa en beijing
buscaba fue una parte activa de rusia en
la actual invasión sobre ucrania
básicamente está diseñado para la
defensa aérea soviética así que va a
tener un impacto en su capacidad a corto
plazo
en su arsenal figuraban 16 misiles presa
dos volcanes desarrollados para destruir
buques de gran calado como portaaviones
a una distancia de 700 kilómetros
buscaba contaba además con un sistema
antiaéreo fort misiles cosa de corto
alcance lanzacohetes cañones y torpedos
era un gigante cuya caída se atribuye
ucrania
es esencialmente un punto adicional de a
nivel moral sobre todo cuando la
rendición de mariupol se muestra más
inevitable puede ser importante tener
exitosa enfrentar a ese otro éxito que
seguramente será magnificado amplificado
por la propaganda rusa por supuesto sí
aunque sí expuesto para popa como wish
bautizado originalmente como özil ya va
una palabra que hace referencia a la
gloria y al ascenso que exhibía la unión
soviética hoy representa la pérdida
militar más importante de rusia desde el
inicio de la invasión a ucrania